I will be replacing Professor
Agarwal today because he is
away.
I am one of the recitation
instructors for those of you who
have not seen me.
We will talk today about a neat
application of RC networks and
expand those to application in
MOS memory systems.
To connect with everything,
we will get back to the basic
circuit that we have been
discussing so far.
And you recall the circuit that
we have been studying,
the canonical RC with an input
voltage function of t.
And we had specified that we
solved this problem for the case
of a step input or a condition
in which a t=0.
At t greater or equal to zero
vI is equal to some capital VI
value that for now on is
constant.
And the other condition that we
discussed was the value of the
voltage on the capacitor that
would exist at time t=0.
Let's call that vc(0).
And in general there is some
finite value here.
It can be zero or it can be
different from zero.
Given that, we learned how to
write down directly,
without messing around with
differential equations,
the answer for the voltage on
the capacitor vc(t),
let me define also my vc right
here, is equal to VI,
the final value,
plus vc(0), the initial value
on the capacitor,
minus the final value,
e^-t/RC.
This is our standard equation
to which we plug in,
and it's either a rising
exponential if VI is larger than
VC or a decaying exponential if
VI is a smaller value than VC.
This should all be familiar.
And, again, as pointed out in
the notes, the reading for today
is 10.3 and for the new material
you should look at Chapter 11
where we discuss memory.
This is where we stood as of
last time.
Now, I would like to discuss a
little bit more about the
storage of charge in capacitors.
And how we can take advantage
of that for storing logic state.
One of the things that I am
sure you must be aware of is
that one of the perhaps most
massively produced chips is
actually the so-called DRAM
which you find in every PC and
every computer that exists
anywhere.
This DRAM is dynamic random
access memory in which we can
store a state and come back and
look at it at any time later,
provided we don't power off our
machine.
The logic state in the basic
memory elements,
of which instead there are
close to 1 giga elements per
chip, are stored on capacitors.
And so we will play a little
bit with that concept today.
And, although we're not going
to discuss the specific example
of the DRAM, the basic elements
of the DRAM you will see
actually in a demo shortly.
So that's the general response
of this network that I have here
to an input VI that happens at
t=0.
Now, the one thing that you
recognize immediately is that it
really doesn't matter what the
value of VI was for t less than
zero.
What really counts is the value
of VI at t=0.
And that's the value that we're
interested in.
Now, there is an implicit
statement in that.
And that statement is that
somehow that network appears
like this at t=0.
So, there has to be some switch
there, and you will see that,
that basically starts my
condition to that at t=0.
And so the history of VI really
doesn't matter.
The response following that
equation that we have there will
depend on the initial value
which is vc(0) here.
Now that is the voltage on the
capacitor at that time.
And then assuming that VI is a
value that is larger than vc(0)
will have a rising exponential
that will come to this value.
And this is the time constant
RC and this is time.
So, the capacitor starts with
some voltage here and goes to a
new voltage that is imposed by
the input for time greater than
zero.
We can define at any one time,
say this time,
this time, this time,
this time the state of the
capacitor.
The state.
What is the state of the
capacitor?
The state is the summary of all
inputs that are relevant to
predicting the future.
If I know the state of the
capacitor this time,
I can predict what it is going
to go given a response VI here
in the future.
So, predicts the future.
Now, what is the state variable
on the capacitor?
What is actually stored on the
capacitor?
You can say,
well, what is stored is
voltage.
The real physical quantity that
is stored is the charge q which
is for linear capacitors related
to the voltage,
let me actually write it
correctly, vc like this.
So, the real state variable is
this.
But for a linear capacitor,
since there is one-to-one
relationship between the two,
v is also a state variable.
OK, so let's then go back to
our original circuit.
What we have is --
-- vc(t), so that's the future
value of the voltage on the
capacitor, is a function of
vc(0), the initial value and the
variable input now in the future
time.
And for the case of vI(t) being
constant VI for t greater or
equal than zero we have the
equation that we just described.
Nothing new.
All the past inputs to the
capacitor for time t less or
equal to zero is summarized in
this value.
And vi being constant the
future is predicted from that.
So, that's the concept of the
state.
There is an initial state on
the capacitor.
And then there is a final state
that will be reached when
equilibrium actually is
achieved.
There is a fair amount of
discussion in the text,
and we don't go in great detail
here, but it is both convenient
for analysis and also it's
interesting in many cases to
look at the response of a linear
network for two different
conditions.
So, we're interested in two
cases.
One is the so-called zero state
response.
Now, what is the zero state
response?
It's the response to a
condition in which we impose an
input and impose also the
condition that the initial
value, initial state of the
capacitor is zero.
So then we ask how does it
respond to vi(t)?
So, starting with a capacitor
at zero state what is the
response?
It allows us to decouple the
initial conditions from the
response to the input.
Now, you will see that this is
actually very useful.
The second condition to which
we're also very interested is
the so-called zero input
response.
What is that?
That is vi(t)=0.
Now, it's the condition under
which there is no input.
vi(t)=0.
The question here is how does
it relax?
We're starting with an initial
state.
So, how this state relaxes out
in the circuit.
Now, the zero state response,
this one here is Z so called SR
for our case,
which I will write like this,
vC, ZSR is simply a rising
exponential.
We start from zero and we go to
VI.
So, it's VI-VI e^-t/RC.
So, that's the ZSR.
The ZIR, the zero input
response is like this.
It's the decay of the initial
voltage on the capacitor to zero
or to equilibrium.
Starting from vC(0) we're
decaying like this.
Now, do you see something
that's rather obvious from
what's on the board in terms of
ZIR and ZSR and the final
complete answer which is there?
They are specific cases,
but how do they relate to the
full answer?
It's the sum.
It's the superposition of the
two.
What basically we see here --
And that's actually a general
statement, is that vC = vC,ZSR +
vC,ZIR.
Now, you may say this is
trivial because we started from
that, ended back in that from
some very simple observations.
However, we are not always
solving networks for responses
that are steps.
The input voltage may be a
ramp.
We did that in recitation.
Or, it could be an impulse.
Or, it can be a more
complicated function.
Having this observation in
place actually allows us to
solve the problem rather neatly.
If I have time at the end,
I might come back to this.
So, this is the same equation
as I started with,
arrived at from a principle of
superposition of two different
solutions.
One application of state which
can be, since we have energy
storage element here,
the capacitor,
which can be stored on the
capacitor is in memory.
And you may ask,
so why do we need a memory node
to perform logic?
Well, there are cases in which
a result depends on previous
results.
So, a computation proceeds in
time.
In order to do that,
we need to store intermediate
results and proceed forward.
One good example is if you're
doing a continuous summation,
say, on your calculator,
you keep putting things in the
memory.
The M+ button,
right?
And you keep adding a series of
numbers.
Every time we store the sum of
the previous operation we add
another number and so on.
Clearly we need some way of
storing state.
For a complete computing
system, we need combinational
logic and we need memory.
In fact, these are the two
basic elements that are
essential for any kind of
computing system.
We need to remember
intermediate results.
We need to remember transient
inputs.
And that's the role that all
these enormous amount of memory
that comes to play in computers
is doing.
The basic memory abstraction is
as follows.
Imagine a block which needs to
be populated by transistor,
resistor, capacitor,
whatever elements.
And it has a control input,
which we will call the store.
It has a state input that we
will call dIN and has an output
dOUT.
When we're telling this
element, OK, now it's time to
store, it looks at the input dIN
and stores it for,
in principle,
an infinite amount of time.
If we were to make a drawing of
this, of what this looks like,
let's suppose,
let me do all this in one axis.
So, time moves this way.
Let's suppose that we have an
input dIN that looks like this,
and the store command comes in
the form of a logic.
Let's actually suggest here
this is logic one,
this is logic zero.
And, although this is not
absolutely necessary,
let's also define that the
store command comes in the form
of a logic one at this store
input.
Store, let's say,
looks like this.
What does the output look like
then in this particular case?
Assuming that the output was
dOUT, the stored element was
zero prior to the store,
then the output would look like
this.
This is dOUT.
As you can see,
it would remember the one that
it saw at this point.
In fact, it would do that
irrespective of what was stored
in this memory cell.
For example,
suppose it was storing one and
the output didn't change,
it's still one.
If it was storing a zero,
it would flip to a one.
If we had another store,
let's say here,
then what happens?
Then it would go back down to
zero because now we sampled an
input that is zero and we
flipped the state.
That's what a memory --
-- element or cell would do for
us.
It would remember the output
state.
And, not only that,
but in principle it should be
undisturbable.
In other words,
I may do something to this dOUT
but it should not flip the
state.
And that comes about quite a
bit.
Because in actual integrated
circuit memory there is lots and
lots and lots of nearest
neighbors to this cell which,
when they're flipped,
have a cross-coupling to the
cell.
The cell must be designed
robust enough that it doesn't
flip, that no coupling actually
occurs.
All right.
Now we're going to try to apply
what we've learned so far to
invent a basic memory element.
And, believe it or not,
this is the key to the DRAM.
Let's implement this in a
circuit.
Suppose I have a switch here
like this.
And I will put a capacitor.
I take my dOUT here.
This is dIN.
And the switch is operated by a
command here that we will call
store.
When store is one it goes up.
When store is zero it is down
here.
That's capacitor C.
This is the storage node.
What are we actually storing in
this case?
Let's suppose that this voltage
here is 5 volts.
I flip the switch up to one and
I flip it back down to zero.
What's the voltage in this
capacitor here?
5 volts.
Now the capacitor is at 5
volts, I put dIN to ground,
flip the switch back up and
then back down to its known
storing condition.
What's the voltage in the
capacitor?
It's zero, exactly.
So, it does store the value of
the voltage that it saw,
five or zero,
high and low.
It stores it because it stores
charge.
That's actually the physical
quantity that's stored.
It's manifested as a voltage,
which we see.
All right.
Now, is this,
oh, before I move from here.
What is the basic cell in a
DRAM, one that you go out and
buy by the billions of cells?
It's actually this.
The only difference is that
this switch here is replaced
with a MOSFET.
And that's all it is.
So, a MOSFET plays the role of
the switch.
When the gate is high this is a
resistor and connects the input
to the capacitor.
And when the gate voltage is
below the threshold voltage this
is an open, as we've seen,
and it isolates the transistor
from the output.
So, that's the basic memory
element.
And, as I said,
it's the key to a DRAM.
OK.
Now let's consider a little bit
the conditions of operation of
this thing.
Let me draw the circuit in two
conditions.
One in which it is storing,
one in which it is sampling and
one in which it is storing.
Not to redraw this thing.
Assuming that I have a MOSFET
there, I would have the on
resistance in place here when
store=1.
Now, in principle,
the output is connected to --
-- some load resistance.
We'll talk a little bit more
about this load resistance in a
minute.
This is the situation when we
are at store=1 situation.
For example,
let's suppose that dIN is 5
volts.
Now, what is the situation for
store=0?
It's very simple.
We have the capacitor C and
dOUT and here we have a
resistance.
The switch is open.
This is store=0 condition.
What we have in this case is we
have a problem similar to what I
was discussing earlier.
It is a ZIR,
if you like,
situation.
And this you can think of as a
ZSR if we're starting with zero
charge on the capacitor,
but I'm interested in this
part.
In this case,
I am starting with a vC(0)=5
volts.
And I'm asking myself how long
will this cell hold the value?
And, in fact,
that is actually what happens
in a dynamic RAM.
The value on the capacitor is
not stored forever.
In fact, that's why we call it
dynamic because we have to come
back and restore it every once
in a while.
For how long are we going to
store the charge?
What's the response of vc for t
greater than zero after the
switch flicked?
It's very simple.
It's vc is equal to 5 volts e
to the minus t over RC,
right?
That's the response.
We have a decay.
And applying to the things we
know.
We start from 5 volts,
let's say here,
I have a decay going down
towards zero,
at some point we are going to
cross the threshold for high.
The only period in which I have
a valid output,
if the capacitor was storing a
one, is this period here.
This is the only period in
which I have valid stored one
because, once I go beyond
capital T here,
I have crossed the legal limit,
threshold for discriminating a
high output.
And from then on the output is
no longer valid.
So, this memory is good
provided time is less than
capital T.
It's not a case in which the
capacitor can hold charge
forever.
In fact, we can calculate,
that is we can solve for T in
this particular case.
It's in your notes.
Nothing really profound.
T is equal to minus RC log VOH
over 5 volts.
So, this is basically what the
response is going to be.
Now, there is an implicit
assumption here,
which is that the store pulse
width is much,
much larger than RON C.
In other words,
when we want to store a one
here starting from zero,
we better charge it all the way
up to 5 volts in the time that
our switch is connected here.
And what is the relevant time
constant?
It's going to be the RON C.
In fact, it's actually the RON
parallel RL with C.
But typically RON is much,
much less than RL so we don't
have to worry about that.
Dominant time constant is RON
C.
So, provided these things are
happening, we have a memory.
Now, we can try to improve
things a little bit.
We see here that we will have a
decay to an invalid state in
time T.
How can we improve things?
One way to improve things are
the buffer.
Here is our memory element
again.
Here is the capacitor.
This is the storing node.
Now I am going to put the
buffering effect.
I am going to put two buffers
here.
Two invertors,
I should say,
because if I am storing a one
here I want to be able to see a
one here as well.
And, in this case,
what I am looking at is the RIN
of the buffer.
And, in principle,
I have out here the RL.
Now, this is better because if
RIN is much larger than RL then
the time T, in this case,
is much larger than the case
without buffer.
So, we buffer the effect of VL.
This could be one of these neat
circuits we saw in recitation
like a source faller,
for example,
or it can be just an inverter
in which case you just see the
input of a transistor.
So, now this condition can be
satisfied.
Let me give you some cases
which are some numbers that are
typical for a dynamic RAM.
Typical times we're talking
about is RIN on order of 1
gigaohm and storage node
capacitor on order of 1
femtofarad to one picofarad.
Now, if you can do the math in
your head, which is just
multiplication,
you will see that the time
constant, the RC is between 1
millisecond to 1 microsecond.
And for DRAMs,
actually, we try to be in the
order of milliseconds.
These are the times we're
talking about.
If I have this kind of circuit,
somehow there has got to be
additional circuitry that comes
back, samples the voltage here
and restores it.
And that is actually what is
happening in a DRAM.
And my laptop is working there
and its DRAM keeps getting
refreshed every,
say, millisecond or whatever
the condition is.
But, in our case,
we are going to do a slightly
different case in which we will
create a static memory.
Let's actually look at,
first of all,
the case of the discharge.
Pay attention to,
let me actually break the loop
here.
This is my capacitor.
This is a resistor that is in
series with a capacitor like you
see here.
Actually, I am going to keep
that resistor in series with the
capacitor, even in this case,
because I have it for my second
part of my example.
I charge the capacitor to 5
volts.
And you can see here this
lights up, I hope everybody can
see it, proportional to the
voltage that I have here.
From here on it's all logic
levels.
So, the intensity of light here
will always be the same.
It's either lit or it's not
lit.
Right now I am charging the
capacitor.
In fact, let's see.
Maybe I can discharge the
capacitor first.
Here the capacitor is
discharged.
As you can see,
the input is zero,
the output is a one,
and then the output of this
inverter here is a one.
I have two inverters in series.
And I am going to charge the
capacitor.
I charged it to 5 volts and
this lit up, this is off of
course, that's an inverter,
this is a valid zero,
produce a valid one.
And now I am going to take the
input out.
As you can see it's stored.
In fact, we have to wait for a
very long time.
We don't have enough time to
wait for this to discharge,
so instead what I am going to
do now is I am going to add also
the resistor.
Now I am going to flip the
resistor in parallel with the
capacitor to imitate what
happens when we have an input
resistance.
You saw that there was a
discharge of the capacitor.
This input level went down.
Voltage here flipped over to a
one.
Let me do it again now with a
resistor in place.
Storing charge on the
capacitor.
That's the store command.
Now, don't store.
I have less,
about a second.
The element here is 20,000
microfarads and 100 ohms which
gives me a time constant of two
seconds.
Assuming a VOC of the order of,
let's say, I don't know what it
is for this case,
2.5, the log would be about
0.5, so it cuts basically the
time to about one.
So, it lasts about one second,
if my math is all correct.
It's actually a little longer
than a second,
excuse me, but the point is
that the charge is gone.
Now, notice,
however, that there is
something I can do here,
which is that suppose I take
the switch or a switch and bring
it back and provide a path from
the output to the input here.
And this switch is open when
this is closed and closed when
this is open.
So, this basically is the
compliment of store.
What I am doing now is I put a
charge here, it produces a valid
one at this point,
and then I am feeding this
valid one back to the input.
As you can see,
this will now allow me,
even though I have a high
resistance, to store the value
for a long time.
In this case,
what I am going to do is I am
going to connect the output,
as you can see here.
And I have my resistor in.
And I am storing zero here,
storing 5 volts.
Now I am going to flip the
switch.
Basically, I mean the don't
store, don't look case.
You notice this dims a little
bit.
Sorry.
No, I want the resistor in.
There.
Yes.
OK, so the output remain value.
This dimmed a little bit but
the output has remained OK.
All right.
So, we've provided a feedback.
Now we've created a static
memory.
This will hold charge for as
long as the circuit is powered
up.
Now, there is still one little
problem that I have with this
kind of configuration.
And that is if I disturb this
output the charge may,
the state may change.
So, for example,
let's say that I have --
I disturbed it by coming close
to it, so let's charge it again.
OK.
I flipped the switch.
I flipped the state from the
output.
That is an invalid condition.
I shouldn't be able to do that.
How do I avoid that?
How can I avoid this problem
that you just saw?
Well, I need yet another
buffer.
The answer is in your notes.
If I don't take the output here
but rather take the output here,
or if I don't want an inverted
output, if I don't want an
inverted output,
I could put yet another element
there.
Then the situation would be
fine.
In this case,
let me do it again.
Charge.
Why isn't this lit?
A bad one?
Now, of course we disturbed the
input.
Now, of course I can do
anything I want here.
Nothing happens,
but you may say this is a
trivial case because this is
already zero.
So, I am going to change the
state.
Here's is the changed state.
See.
I can show this.
Nothing happens up there.
So, this is an interesting
situation in which I am
buffering the output so that the
output does not feed back to the
input.
And, by and large,
in designing circuits this is
something that we do.
Now, in the remaining three
minutes there is an example that
we have.
Can we put the laptop here?
OK, so here is an example of
how memory can be put together
now to create something a little
bit more complicated.
And you can see the memory
cells that we were discussing
here.
There's four of them,
so this is a four bit memory.
There is a decoder at the
beginning here which decodes the
address of each cell,
so the input here will tell me
which cell I need to address.
Let's look at the truth table.
This is the truth table for the
decoder.
As you can see,
depending on the address that I
have here, this is zero,
one, two and three in a binary
system, only A,
B, C or D is up,
is high.
Which means that this end
operation here only allows the
input that is presented to all
of the cells,
what is going through the AND
gate here to appear at the
output.
If, for example,
we have a one,
zero, the only end input that
is going to be high is going to
be this one.
And that means the only cell
that will look at the input when
the store comes up is going to
be this one here.
At that point it will store
whatever is on the input cell
because that's an AND operation.
That is a simple example of a
memory.
And following that simple
arrangement you can build
incredibly large memory systems.
So, that's all I had for today.
And I will see you on Tuesday.